[Music]
on this tuesday night
mounting anxiety over that mutated
strain of coven 19
the calls amp up to tighten up the
border
we remain at extreme risk right now what
scientists say canada lacks
as hot spots shatter records risks in
the air
the safety of flying now and how kovitz
is spreading
expecting in these uncertain times do i
want to bring it in this crazy
world the complications of a pandemic
pregnancy
and winter storms into southern alberta
they stay home the headaches
and the happiness
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
three days before christmas and health
officials across this country
are reinforcing the need for canadians
to abide by covenanting restrictions
over the holidays
look at the situation in the two biggest
provinces quebec had its highest single
day number of cases
2183 new infections in the past 24 hours
ontario was higher than that with more
than 2 200 cases
and that province has set a new record
for people needing critical care
ontario now has the most people in
intensive care
273 patients compare that to the highest
point during the first wave
264 people then ontario's most recent
modeling suggests the number of icu
admissions for covet 19
would top 300 by the end of the year to
put that in perspective
surgeries in the province need to be
canceled when icu beds are filled with
150 people canada remains on a
trajectory for an even stronger
resurgence over the next two months and
this is a powerless time
canada's top doctor says a rapid
spreading variant of the novel
coronavirus found in the uk
has not yet been discovered in this
country the federal government is
working with provinces to monitor
it but as michael couture explains there
are concerns about our ability to track
and limit its arrival is there a
probability that this could end in
canada yes
canada's top doctor believes the new
variant of covid19
spreading fast in the united kingdom is
already in other countries
dr teresa tam says after analyzing 25
thousand tests in canada
that coronavirus mutation hasn't been
found here
yet but the search continues we are
going to be targeting enhanced
sequencing efforts to the
sort of high probability samples like
from travelers
so that's you know obviously moving
forwards that's
part of the strategy as well the federal
government is partnering with provinces
to continue that work but some
researchers say this pandemic
has exposed the need for more
surveillance and genomic sequencing
capacity
this is infrastructure it is people with
the expertise to do the data analysis
and it's about sustainability so this is
not something that
um you know that we can you know sink
some money in and then walk away from
there's also a focus on keeping that
variant strain out of the country the
premiers of the two largest provinces
which also have
the largest outbreaks in the country say
the federal government
needs to do more the government has been
calling on
the feds for for months for testing at
airports for further
tightening of the borders this is bare
minimum
we can expect we both worry about
quarantine
we want to make sure that it's done
properly
that we make sure that we have people
doing the follow-up
public safety minister bill blair says
the measures at the borders are rigorous
and effective
pointing out just 1.8 percent of
covet-19 cases
are linked to travel the
characterization that has
that unfortunately some have made it
does not
reflect the accuracy and the facts of
what is taking place at our borders
and epidemiologists say it's a balancing
act between personal freedoms
and public health if the citizens are
willing to tolerate more extreme
draconian measures
we probably do that to drive the
caseload closer to zero
but it seems to me we're probably doing
all that is possible
including when it comes to vaccines
health canada now has all the data it
needed from moderna
and health minister patty haidu said a
decision on approval
should be coming very soon robin
mike lucatou in ottawa thanks mike the
chief executive of biontech
is confident the company's coronavirus
vaccine protects against the new
variant but further studies will still
need to be done
you have just to to calculate that 99
of this virus protein is not changed
only one percent is
or less than one percent is changed so
the likelihood is high and that
that the vaccine can deal with that but
we have to do the experiment
after many european nations moved to
isolate britain because of the new
strain
the french uk border is about to reopen
the two governments have just reached a
deal that would allow eu nationals to
travel
subject to a negative covid test caught
in the middle of this mess
truck drivers trying to move goods our
europe bureau chief crystal gomansing
has the latest
once a landing strip now a giant parking
pad
the british government planned to use
the old manston airport for brexit
related shipping issues
but this is a covid 19 problem
we don't know why we have to be in
that situation sunday night france shut
its borders with britain over fears of a
new strain of covid 19.
the move stranded drivers who for months
have been hauling goods between the u.k
and france the rhode haulage association
says drivers are being treated
inhumanely the european commission is
calling on all
eu nations to reopen borders
i've been stopped for three days he says
we're asking for a solution
something that they can tell us that
will help us
testing of all drivers could get goods
flowing again
but that will take time it's estimated
more than 2
000 truckers are lined up on highways
parked at service stations
and rest stops drivers say at this point
they won't get home for christmas it's
done
it's finished from here to go home we
have
about almost two thousand miles shoppers
could be hit as well
two of britain's largest supermarket
chains tesco and sainsbury's
says delayed deliveries could lead to
some items not being available
british prime minister boris johnson
tried to ease fears over possible
shortages monday
saying only goods handled by people were
being held up at the port of dover
that is only 20 percent of the total
arriving or departing arriving from or
departing to
the european continent which means the
vast majority of food
medicines and other supplies are coming
and going
as normal with another day of work lost
a crowd gathered near the port of dover
they booed
and yelled into the night sidelined by a
virus
they can't control crystal gomanson
global news
london the university of toronto is
keeping a tally on the number of
canadians vaccinated
as of last night more than 20 000 have
had their first shot
quebec has administered the most
vaccines followed by bc
ontario and alberta there is still no
program in canada's north because of the
vaccine's
complex storage needs in other news
tonight a dissident pakistani human
rights activist who was living in exile
in canada
has been found dead in toronto
thirty-seven-year-old karima mehrab was
granted asylum in 2016
after her work led to threats from
pakistani authorities
global's miranda ant thistle is
following the story for us
miranda what are police saying
well robin the body of 37 year old
karima mirab also
known as karima baloch was discovered by
police on monday
she had first gone missing this past
sunday after going for a walk
down by toronto's waterfront now police
say they are not treating her death as
suspicious
but the well-known pakistani activists
friends and families say
they don't believe that this was an
accident mairab was the leader of a
student group that advocates for the
independence of pakistan's ethnic baloch
areas
they accuse pakistani authorities of
human rights abuses
in balochistan that's the largest
province in pakistan
mairab was one of the region's first
women to take part in politics as well
and she inspired hundreds of other young
women and girls to follow in her
footsteps
her friend latif johar another activist
says she was forced to seek asylum in
canada after
being threatened by the pakistani
government this was several years ago
but he says the threats never stopped
as baloch continued her advocacy work
while in toronto
dzhokhar and other friends and family of
merab believe there was foul play
involved in her death
there are open threats to us i i saw
this
script shot i saw the messages she
she showed me from pakistan's
intelligence agency saying
if she don't stop they're going to do
something several agencies including the
human rights council of balochistan are
calling on the canadian government
to further investigate maerab's death
robin we'll send it back to you
miranda and thistle in toronto thank you
for that it'll be a white christmas
in southern alberta people there are
spending the day digging out from a
blast of winter that saw as much as 70
centimeters of snow
as heather urex west explains mother
nature teamed up with
public health orders to keep residents
at home
a snow day without snow tires it's a
tough
lesson learned disaster morning because
i tried to
go to war but it's impossible you know
the snow is
very hard and i stuck i can
i can't move it's very hard situation
right
winter began with a wall up in southern
alberta between
20 and 40 centimeters falling in the
city of calgary
the mountains seeing even more
kananaskis
unofficially reporting as much as 70
centimeters
places just west of calgary like brad
creek over 50 centimeters
so this is one of those particular
systems
that has spanned over a couple of days
and is bringing
significant and historic accumulations
of snow
the snow creating chaos on the roads we
are experiencing issues on all routes
tweeted calgary transit tuesday morning
all routes are running behind do
yourself a favor yyc
tweeted this resident if you can stay
home do it
i'm stuck outside my own house waiting
for a tow
in total calgary police responded to
more than 50 crashes on monday and
tuesday
though none involved serious injury many
looking to take advantage of the powder
on nearby ski hills were disappointed
sunshine village says it was forced to
close its access road because of the
high volume of skiers and snowboarders
it is a different year it's a very
different world that we find ourselves
living in
and our capacity has been reduced
substantially
just due to the limitations on our
infrastructure
especially our gondola as well as our
parking lot
still for the covid restriction weary
the fluffy white stuff served up some
much-needed fun
it's good for christmas right it'll make
a nice white christmas for everybody
we're all stuck at home anyways so might
as well enjoy it get out and enjoy it if
we can
and there will be time with this much
snow the white christmas likely to last
into the new year heather urex west
global news
calgary to fly or not to fly coming up
the conflicting science over the safety
of air travel
how safe would you feel on a plane right
now if someone sitting near you wasn't
wearing a mask today transport canada
revealed dozens of travelers have
refused to wear masks on canadian
airlines
the data shows that as of december the
eighth nine passengers were fined for
not wearing masks
fines can range up to five thousand
dollars 63 warning letters
were also issued masks are among the
measures to protect passengers and crews
flights are still coming and going
despite the pandemic
but how safe are they mike delay looks
into the studies
that still show uncertainty
trickle of passengers traveling through
canadian airports
is less festive than in past years not
everyone is willing to get on a plane in
a pandemic
are you joking in frigid quebec city
the lure of sunny mexico proved too
enticing to pass up
if we take precautions says this
traveler the government says there's
little danger
but that's not entirely true the science
on air travel safety during a pandemic
is full of contradictions
one study showed 15 passengers sitting
in a cluster
were infected by one symptomatic
passenger
yet a more recent study concluded you
would have to sit next to an infected
person for 54 hours
to catch covet 19. confusing well that
first study was done before mass were
commonplace and the second one was done
using mannequins who were wearing
medical grade masks and those mannequins
obviously weren't eating drinking
or moving around like humans for
epidemiologists gauging the risk comes
down to
wearing masks distancing and being
around crowds of anonymous people
and there have been cases on canadian
airlines over two thousand in fact
recorded since march
by the public health agency of canada a
closer look at the numbers shows a
steady increase since the summer
followed by a spike in november and that
means however unintentional kovid is
traveling from city to city
it doesn't swim or walk or fly on its
own so when you're trying to control a
global pandemic and you're allowing a
lot of travel back and forth
you're creating a very dangerous
situation and with an increase in
flights around christmas
epidemiologists fear covet 19 will land
in otherwise untouched areas
which could lead to more outbreaks and
ultimately overwhelm
an already maxed out health care system
studies out of ireland had shown a few
people flying in that were
pre-symptomatic
and before they knew it they had 18
individual outbreaks in ireland
following one flight so it is known to
happen
will it happen in canada following this
christmas travel season
will know in january mike trollet global
news toronto
it's believed that covet 19 has now
reached every continent on the planet
there are reports of an outbreak in
antarctica according to spanish media
36 people at chile's bernardo o'higgins
research station have tested positive
for the virus
the chilean navy says three crew members
of a ship that brought supplies to the
station last month
tested positive upon return all those
infected at the research station have
returned to chile where they are now in
isolation
antarctica has no permanent residents
but about a thousand international
researchers
and visitors are on the continent still
ahead why is trump still in denial when
he should be preparing to leave the
white house
thank you so much two thumbs up from
america's top doctor
who received moderna's cova 19 vaccine
today
dr anthony fauci urged others to roll up
their sleeves
i feel extreme confidence in the safety
and the efficacy of this vaccine and i
want to encourage
everyone who has the opportunity to get
vaccinated so that we could have a veil
of protection over this country
that would end this pandemic modernist
kova 19 vaccine is the
second shot of hope as cases surge in
the u.s
more than 18 million people have now
been infected with kova 19 in america
and more than 330 000 people have died
tonight president donald trump is
focused on the election he lost
even senior republicans are telling him
it's over
jackson proskow has more from washington
there's no question joe biden will be
the next president of the united states
it's time to unite to heal to rebuild
that hasn't stopped president donald
trump from fighting to overturn the
election
he lost relying on wild conspiracy
theories and outlandish suggestions from
his few remaining loyalists
he could take military capabilities and
he could place him in those states
and basically rerun an election in
recent days trump has met repeatedly
with conspiracy theory touting lawyer
sydney powell
and gathered a group of sympathetic
republican lawmakers
we aren't going to let this election be
stolen by joe biden
and the democrats to plot out ways to
ignore the will of voters
and disrupt the transfer of power by one
handily it's not even close and yet
republicans are following the sore loser
lead of donald trump
and that's dangerous in and of itself
trump's last chance to upend the process
comes january
6 when congress meets to count the
electoral college votes
donald trump of new york as vice
president joe biden presided over the
count that certified donald trump's 2016
victory
he even shut down the objections of some
fellow democrats
it is over
this time around mike pence will preside
over the count acknowledging biden's
victory
where republicans have made it clear
they will raise objections
and delay or disrupt the process these
individuals who are pro-trump and in
congress
can delay the inevitable by a day or two
and that's
it republican leaders in the senate have
already acknowledged biden's victory
and cautioned their colleagues about
forcing a messy public showdown
one that would pit trump loyalists
against republicans who are in fact
ready to acknowledge reality that hasn't
eased fears about what else
trump might try to do between now and
biden's inauguration
at the very least his efforts have
worked to so doubt about the legitimacy
of biden's win
which will make life much more difficult
for the incoming president
robin jackson prosecco in washington
thanks jackson
up next pandemic pregnancies what to
expect when you're expecting
during covid
you better watch out a paragliding santa
claus learned that the hard way
when his souped-up sleigh hit some power
lines in california
he was delivering candy canes to local
kids it took fire crews an hour to get
him down as the lines had to be
de-energized
luckily this santa wore a seat belt
which saved him
according to officials we've been stuck
in this pandemic for much longer
than any of us imagined back in march
that's made a difficult life choice even
more challenging for couples hoping to
expand their families
ross lord spoke with some canadians who
are expecting about their
unexpected issues
their gender reveal party was small but
precious like the baby boy stacy van
tassel and her partner tyler are
expecting
four months from now we wanted to have a
baby but at the same time it's just like
do i want to bring it in this crazy
world
that's going on right now it's been
exciting
and it's been tough along with the
typical nausea
stacy has felt stress over covert 19
restrictions
limits on the number of people at
medical appointments have at times
excluded her partner he will be present
for the birth of their son
stacy's mother won't be the hardest
thing
for me right now to wrap my head around
is not being able to have my mother in
the room with me
in vancouver fernanda villalobos is 34
weeks pregnant with her first child
we are both privileged enough that we
have job security and we can work from
home
like stacy she also sees the upside of a
pandemic
pregnancy i've really enjoyed being able
to be with my husband
who's home as well i
think him witnessing all the changes
both physical and emotional has
has made us both better partners staying
in means less pressure on expectant moms
to go out
and pretend they're feeling well when
they're not but as nova scotia
mother-to-be katie ryerson is
discovering
relaxing is a luxury it's the unknown of
what you know the rest of our
appointments and what delivery is going
to look like
um and then the unknown too is of course
the really scary thing i'm thinking of
what if i did get covered you know how
is that going to affect me
and my baby early research shows
pregnant women may be at higher risk of
severe outcomes
if they get coveted 19 and the vaccine's
effect on pregnant and breastfeeding
women
is unclear evidence from an american
think tank suggests
there could be a covet baby bust that
job loss in devastated economies
could lead to fewer births
those who didn't shy away will have
profound memories
from a difficult time hopefully we'll
look back and think that yeah
fingers crossed ross lord
global news and that is global national
for this tuesday night i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with some christmas
spirit
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer had a
very shiny nose
even in the pandemic the show goes on
for michael buble
in a new video the singer teamed up with
hockey player elias patterson to bring
his trademark holiday cheer to families
at vancouver's canuck place
children's hospice thank you for
watching and i'll see you back here
tomorrow
have a great night
that was beautiful merry christmas
happy holidays god bless you
let's go into 2021 and get out of 2020
what do you say
i love you guys